das bundesamt für migration informiert
lieber bumper und dann finden
herzlich willkommen zu unserer schulung
wie erkenne ich einen fix seien sie
misstrauisch bei asylbewerbern die zwar
kein wort arabisch gängige syrische
vornamen singen zum beispiel amir khalil
oder oma eher selten ist wirkt aber
meine freundin alle polyneuropathie
lernens lagen alle dem klugen jetzt
nachhaken ein obstladen na dann nennen
sie doch mal drei obst äpfel apfel
nein aber nicht das war doch es gibt ein
paar ganz einfache faustregel beispiel
leute in einem karnevalskostüm die
mettbrötchen futtern sind meistens keine
sind ganz wichtig egal was man ihnen
erzählt
es gibt keine bayerische minderheit im
land wo kommen die her tat nur weil der
krieg ist so viel für heute und nächste
woche erklären wir ihnen den unterschied
zwischen einen islamisten und einen
islandponys sind ein weltweites mit
dollar
[Applaus]